bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
au parlement européen à bruxelles pour
cette nouvelle édition d' europe hebdo
et dans cette émission grands reportages
en roumanie où entre un million et demi
et deux millions de roms vivent dans des
conditions extrêmement difficiles et
certains d'entre eux voudraient aller
dans l'ouest de l'europe et puis
l'actualité c'est un programme phare de
l'union européenne erasmus est il menacé
de disparition faute d'argent c'est la
question de la semaine
l'espagne a placé ce moyen xavier
français de 25 ans part à barcelone pour
terminer ses études en économie
l'aventuré race musko mance popularisé
par le film de cédric klapisch
ça c'était le bon vieux temps car
l'auberge espagnole pourrait bientôt
devenir un film d'époque très populaire
en europe le programme d'échangé
universitaire créée en 1987 est menacée
de disparition
l'année même de son anniversaire
il n'y aurait plus assez d'argent pour
continuer à financer les études sans
frontières des jeunes citoyens européens
la crise a conduit certains états
membres à réduire leurs contributions au
budget de l'union européenne et à
limiter certaines dépenses
erasmus en fait les frais chaque année
grâce à une bourse moyenne de 366 euros
quelques 230 mille étudiants font
plusieurs mois d'études ou de stages
dans un autre pays une occasion
d'apprendre la culture et la langue des
voisins en france le premier ministre
souhaite que le programme erasmus monte
en puissance pour qu'il bénéficie à plus
d'étudiants issus de familles modestes
pourtant au parlement européen le
président de la commission des budgets
alain lamassoure tire la sonnette
d'alarmé
faute de moyens le programme sera
bientôt en cessation de paiement alors
erasmus est il déjà mort
retour à bruxelles nous sommes avec
sylvie guillaume bonjour je députée
européenne membre du groupe des
socialistes et démocrates merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors erasmus
c'est sans doute l'un des programmes les
plus symboliques les plus populaires en
europe alain lamassoure votre collègue
du groupe ppe affirme que ce programme
est menacé d'extinction est-ce que
erasmus va mourir
j'ai fait le pari que non et je pense
que nous serons nombreux à faire ce pari
là mais monsieur lamassoure a fait un
coup de génie il a fait un buzz
absolument parfait justement prenant
appui sur le fait que erasmus est non
seulement un programme qui fonctionne
mais un programme qui a été repérée qui
est très visible et qui parle à beaucoup
d'européens moi je ne pense pas que le
programme est race ne soit menacée il ya
un problème de liquidités de trésorerie
positif et le bon sens qui dit n'était
pas tout à fait exact j'aime la
situation mais je pense qu'il utilise
parfaitement bien une technique de
communication qui va permettre de
rebondir sur d'autres sujets ce qu'il me
semble que monsieur lamassoure voulais
dire c'est qu'il ya une vraie
problématique sur les fonds sociaux et
qu'il ya une vraie problématique
également plus générale sur le budget et
en prenant ce sujet tout à fait
emblématique de la jeunesse de l'accès à
d'autres cultures de la libre
circulation de la confrontation des
langues et des études bref houcine un
moyen de répondre à la crise aussi il a
pris un sujet parfaitement symbolique
pour je crois stigmatisé le fait que
certains états membres sont très
réticents à apporter le budget européen
sont très réticents à aller vers des
budgets qui sont
j'ai de lutte contre la crise et pour la
croissance et donc je crois qu'il
voulait stigmatiser sa sur l'avenir en
fait c'est un appel lancé aux états
membres pour qu'ils mettent plus
d'argent dans le budget communautaire
qui est réduit par rapport aux autres
années c'est un peu un budget de crise
c'est ça le zilina je crois je crois
qu'il y as a généralement sur le budget
c'est à dire comment on se donne les
moyens de sortir de la crise d'aller
vers des politiques de relance et c'est
vrai que le vin budget européen fort
bien bâti qui agit en ce sens est un
moyen de surmonter un certain nombre de
difficultés que rencontrent les états
membres dans leur territoire donc il y a
je crois ça il est aussi je pense aussi
mais vous latéraux j'aurais peut-être il
à la répartition entre les différents
fonds les fonds de cohésion les fonds de
la pac moi je pensais avec mon groupe
aussi que les fonds de cohésion sont
fondamentaux justement pour aider les
états membres sortir de la crise donc je
crois que il y avait aussi ça qui est en
ligne de compte comment on contribue
comment on renforce ses fonds sociaux
européens justement c'est la grande
question en temps de crise et les états
manquent d'argent il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'argent dans les caisses d'où peut
venir l'argent et surtout quels
arbitrages doit-on faire puisque on peut
maintenir décidé de maintenir le fonds
social européen erasmus mais est-ce que
ça n'implique pas que d'autres
programmes doivent être sacrifiés
sacrifier n'est pas le bon terme à mon
avis je pense qu'il ya manifestement à
travailler faire sur la consommation des
fonds ce travail de fond il doit être
fait sur rs mus par exemple on a modifié
le programme sera modifié pour être
élargi à plus de public puisqu'on avait
constaté effectivement que il y avait
certaines bourses qui n'était pas
consommer c'est le cas en france
peut-être là aussi parce que la crise
aidant les gens
- les jeunes ont un peu envie peut-être
de rester sur des formations courtes en
prenant moins de risques pour essayer
d'assurer leur avenir dans un contexte
qui est assez délicat est assez
difficile donc il y avait manifestement
à travailler sur l'adéquation de ses
fonds avec les besoins et la
consommation qui en était fait adopter
un travail de fourmi sur comment ces
fonds sont bien utilisés mais plus
globalement dans un contexte de crise où
chaque pays pris isolément ne pourra pas
s'en sortir seuls s'ils continuent
d'agir dans un contexte très très
restreint de ses frontières il faut
qu'ils aient une impulsion il fonde
manifestement que l'europe agisse à son
bon niveau et son bon niveau si la
solidarité c'est bastia c'est le
financer cela c'est l'objet de la
discussion budgétaire qui est en cours
actuellement entre le parlement et le
conseil qu'est-ce qu'ils sont un peu
tendus effectivement vous dites il faut
qu'il y ait un sursaut v12 petit venir
on dit quand même la même chose depuis
depuis des années qu'ils qu'il faut que
ça change mais on a l'impression que ce
que la crise est toujours là et que les
choses n'avancent pas d'où peut venir
sur lutter contre la crise apprend le
diverses formules et divers biens et
la fois le traité et puis les
discussions que nous avons depuis
plusieurs années au plan européen je
crois que commence à marquer les frites
c'est le cas par exemple avec la taxe
sur les transactions financières on voit
qu'on avance sur un certain le sujet
mais c'est très long c'est trop long et
on s'est toujours plaint effectivement
en tout cas dans mon groupe de la
petitesse l'étroitesse des réactions et
surtout du délai de ce type de réaction
moi je crois que deux années durant le
parlement a été très ferme dans ses
convictions mais a lâché à ce conseil et
face à l'augmentation nécessaire et du
budget en tout cas une stabilisation sur
réellement les moyens de répondre aux
besoins des citoyens
on a lâché deux fois peut-être que la
troisième fois ce sera une autre une
autre affaire une autre façon de voir
les choses et que le parlement sera
beaucoup une ferme sur les prix est ce
que vous pensez qu'il va naître sur ce
programme erasmus qui continue à
intéresser beaucoup beaucoup de jeunes
en europe ce qui a quand même plus de
trente deux cent trente mille étudiants
qui bénéficient de ces bosses est-ce que
sur erasmus il y aura quelque chose et
ce qu'est ce que ça va être ce qui va
être sauvegardés sympa je pense que le
programme erasmus comme on le disait au
démarrage à un problème de liquidités de
trésorerie qui sera surmontée parce que
dans le même temps les états présentent
les factures donc à un moment donné et
ce qu'elles disent que les états
consomme pour leurs citoyens
présentant la facture les commissions
impôts bien qui est que cela est
nécessaire donc je pense qu'il n'y aura
pas de soucis sur erasme et ce en quoi
cette année évidemment et que la
discussion budgétaire sur l'année
prochaine sera manifestement très rude
et très axé sur la sauvegarde des des
programmes sociaux et des programmes en
direction de la jeunesse ça se sait
vraiment un pari que nous devons faire
collectivement merci sylvie guillaume on
a bien compris votre message
alors cette semaine on a parlé d'un pays
en crise l'espagne un catalan défi
madrid artur mas c'est son nom le
gouverneur de la région appelle à des
élections anticipées et veut faire
sécession regardez ce zapping des
télévisions européennes
des élections régionales anticipées
seront organisées le 25 novembre en
catalogne le parti d'artur mas le
président de la communauté autonome
pourrait obtenir la majorité absolue de
quoi renforcer les velléités
d'indépendance de la région
le président de catalogne n'a fait
qu'une seule chose signer le décret de
convocation des élections anticipées il
appelle sa région à s'émanciper de la
peur et des menaces
il n'y a pas besoin d'avoir peur puisque
aujourd'hui personne ne peut utiliser
des armes unilatéralement contre son
peuple
personne ne peut utiliser les armes
contre un peuple qui s'exprime
démocratiquement pacifiquement et à la
majorité
en signant le décret artur mas a assuré
que le mouvement d'émancipation de la
catalogne serait pacifique et que
personne ne devrait menacer ce mouvement
ils veulent que la catalogne devienne un
pays et non plus une région l'espagne
le nationalisme catalan est déjà
important mais il est exacerbé par la
crise économique prix explosent en
catalogne une région qui est au bord de
la faillite
voilà alors nous avons été rejoints par
griselda pastor bonjour merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes correspondante ici à
bruxelles de la radio espagnole cadena
ser alors l'espagne est déjà aux prises
avec une crise économique importante
on voit qu'il ya là une
sombre tempête constitutionnel en tout
cas vu de france est-ce que kiki et 7
artur mas est ce qu'il ya vraiment une
menace aujourd'hui de sécession delà de
la catalogne ou alors est ce que c'est
de la provocation
c'est difficile à dire comment ça va
finir bon alors menacé le président du
gouvernement catalan
il a été élu
après un gouvernement de gauche
socialiste gauche ni
gauche indépendantiste
il est un peu l'héritage dans le très
charismatique qui s'appelle sur des
pujols qui a été le président de la
planète pendant toute la transition
et jusqu'à l'arrivée de ce nouveau
gouvernement de gauche
ce qui est nouveau c'est que ces partis
nationalistes n'a jamais été un parti
indépendantiste c'est parti nationaliste
a fait la transition espagnole en
expliquant aux catalans que
l'indépendance n'avait plus de sens dans
un espace démocratique mais que les
catalans était une nation mais dont la
vocation n'était pas d'être
indépendantiste qu'est ce qui a changé
maintenant bon la crise certainement
c'est un élément très important mais il
faut voir aussi en p tous les problèmes
dans lesquels
l'état espagnol et schumi alors
justement que demandent précisément les
les catalans et plus particulièrement
artur mas il reproche de trop donné
d'argent à
madrid y un problème fiscal
oui il ya un problème fiscal il ya un
problème fiscal qui est historique donc
la droite catalane piété droite il faut
il faut la place et il faut la placer
cette droite
qui est intégrée par une coalition donc
le parti démocrate chrétien et fondateur
de la démocratie chrétienne européenne
donc membre de la démocratie chrétienne
internationale en tout petit parti
démocratique est à l'union et après vous
savez c'est parti combat c'est monsieur
démocrate qui est en partie du parti
libéral européen et si on dans les
groupes libéraux donc
depuis toute une histoire politique il
considère qu'il ya un problème d'argent
entre la catalogne et l'espagne c'est ce
permanent d'entraidé campagne électorale
il ya un problème il ya un problème
aggravé parce que le pays basque et
n'avait autant concert économique pour
bien comprendre ça veut dire qu'il ya
des régions dans l'espagne qui ramassent
des impôts qui les utilisent et qui rend
à l'état c'est dont ils ont pu les
joindre iliad il ya des régions qui
reçoit dans le teint c'est que l'état
leur donne ce qu'ils veulent aujourd'hui
des catalans en fait est ce qu'on
reproche à madrid faux ça c'est très
difficile à dire en très peu de temps
mais voyons l'espagne a fini transition
il ya une guerre civile gagné par franco
quarante années de dictature donc
d'espagne bien commencé une transition
dans laquelle tout le monde doit céder
en paix mais donc il faut effacer
certains fantômes du passé donc la
catalogne fait la transition en parlant
d' indépendance et liberté et arrive à
la transition un devoir reconstituer ses
discours pour dire ça n'a plus de sens
dans un état démocratique
il ya une constitution qui essayent de
réfléter la pluralité de l'état le
problème c'est que dans ces moments
présents
l'idée de cette constitution a touché
son toit est acquise et surtout en
catalogne mais qu l'état espagnol ne
veut pas ou ne peut pas la changer parce
que ils ont le parti qui a la majorité
absolue et en espagne avait pas se
permettre ça est-ce que vous pensez que
ce type de mouvement peut être dangereux
pour l'espagne et plus généralement pour
l'europe bien sûr c'est toujours
d'énormes dangers quand il ouvre quand
tu ouvres quelque chose qui implique des
changements terrible que tu sais pas où
ils vont mais quelles sont les
nouveautés dont il ya un parti
nationaliste qui n'a jamais été
indépendantiste qui tout en cours ceux
des poussées par le citoyen et qui n'a
d'autre choix que de demander
l'indépendance qui a une partie
majoritaire en espagne qui étant partis
unitaristes absolue qui est confronté à
une dégradation de l'état avec une
monarchie qui s'effondre qui étaient les
symboles de l'état pendant des années et
une crise terrible comment ça va finir
on a n'a aucune idée eh bien merci
beaucoup griselda pastor de nous avoir
exposé ses quelques éléments d'éclairage
en si peu de temps alors je propose de
partir maintenant en roumanie nous
sommes allés près de bucarest à la
rencontre de la communauté rom objet de
vives polémiques en france nous avons
voulu comprendre quel était leur
situation leur sort le sort de ces
citoyens roumains dans leur propre pays
c'est un reportage signé ahmed tazir
avec georges et à beaucourt
il est midi passé leur premier repas de
la journée des pommes de terre et des
champignons les enfants sont impatients
de manger ou cuisine à l'extérieur une
famille rom comme il en existe beaucoup
en roumanie 11 enfants et petits enfants
à nourrir eger guina dimitriou ne
perçoit que l'équivalent de 20 euros par
mois dette sociale
moi je suis dans la galère pas
d'électricité depuis 25 ans pado on est
livrés à nous mêmes nous sommes à flot
ou tchané une vingtaine de kilomètres de
bucarest un village comme beaucoup
d'autres roms et roumains ne se croise
pas des roumains plutôt à l'aise des
roms dans le dénuement des conditions de
vie difficiles pour guina d'autant plus
que son mari ne peux pas l'aider il est
invalide green a bien pensé a immigré en
france ou ailleurs pour améliorer son
sort moi je partirai bien en france mais
regardée j'ai personnes marguiller c'est
qui va s'occuper de vue légal guina
n'est pas la seule à vouloir partir
qu'elle ya vit avec son mari dans cette
baraque 20 euros mensuels dette sociale
pour tous revenus et un désir profond
d'immigrés plus vers l'ouest vers
l'autre europe moi j'y vais en france
même pour mendier parce qu'ici personne
ne fait attention à nous personne ne
nous donne rien ne serait ce qu'une
baguette florine la vingtaine marié deux
enfants lui avec ses parents ici c'est
là où on dort tous sont à venir il ne
l'imaginent pas en roumanie
moi je pense sérieusement à partir en
france à ramener toute ma famille et si
y'a aucun débouché il n'y a pas de bio
la mairie nous dit qu'ils n'ont rien à
nous donner
la solution didine à la trouver pour
faire vivre ses frères et soeurs elle
est devenue une habituée des allers
retours entre la région parisienne et la
roumanie en france je bosse dans le
recyclage de métaux la ferraille je fais
des poubelles je gagne 40 à 50 euros par
mois
non par jour mais ni
sa maison elle l'a payé grâce à l'aide
versée par la france lors de sa première
expulsion j'ai reçu 300 euros d aide au
retour
vous allez retourner en france pour
encore avoir cette aide
non parce qu'on ne redonnera plus cette
aide au retour mais peut-être que je
trouverai un français et que je vais me
marier avec lui
un désir d'eldorado pour fuir une
discrimination vécue au quotidien
l'histoire du pont de from chagny et
symbolique ilinca et rome ces enfants
utilisaient ce raccourci pour aller à
l'école des roumains l'ont détruit pour
ne plus voir ces gamins passer devant
leur maison on les accuse de plusieurs
vols
mais rouvin là haut ils veulent plus que
nous les roms on passe devant chez eux
et ça c'est depuis qu'on a volé lavage
de monsieur florica on s'en prend
toujours à nous c'est pas vrai vous
savez les roms et les romains on est
tous pareils il ya des bons et des
mauvais comme partout ironie de
l'histoire notre vieille roumaine va
trébucher sur le pont cassé
et c'est un homme qui va l'aider à se
relever
merci ça m'a fait plaisir que tu mets et
des
douches
des roms qui rêvent d'eldorado qui se
sentent discriminés à la mairie de
funchal ni on ne se sent pas concerné
ce que j'ai observé de plus important
c'est le manque de dialogue entre roms
et roumains depuis longtemps et puis les
roms considère que la mairie peut tout
résoudre on leur a jamais expliqué que
certains problèmes elles ne sont pas de
notre ressort
d'après jelloud dominique que la
question rom n'est pas prioritaire pour
le gouvernement son association est de
cette population dans tout le pays est
sur le terrain il constate que les
autorités ne font rien pour retenir ceux
qui veulent partir et pour cause
les autorités ont intérêt à ce qu'il y
ait une forte communauté à l'extérieur
du pays
quand on regarde les statistiques
tous les ans les roumains ça inclut les
roms qui sont à l'étranger envoient un
milliard deux cent mille euros c'est une
somme qui représente 1 % du pib
saper le système éducatif
le système de santé en roumanie tous les
salaires sont payés grâce à cet argent
en roumanie il serait plus de deux
millions les roms ils forment le
tiers-monde de l'europe aujourd'hui
légalement ceux qui n'ont pas de contrat
de travail peuvent rester au maximum
trois mois en france voilà pourquoi il
ya encore des expulsions mais en 2014 le
cadre légal changera c'est la fin de la
période de transition pour la roumanie
les roms pourront rester aussi longtemps
qu'ils le souhaitent en france avec la
bénédiction des autorités roumaines
un reportage en roumanie signé ahmed
tazir alors nous avons été rejoint sur
ce plateau par cristian preda bonjour
vous êtes eurodéputés romain vous êtes
du groupe ppe ici au parlement européen
à bruxelles on a vraiment le sentiment
qu'en roumanie à les roumains d'un côté
les hommes de l'autre est ce que la
situation des roms
ça fait l'objet d'un débat national chez
vous oui ça fait débat bien sûr avant
que le débat soit organisé en france et
dans les autres pays membres de l'union
bien sûr ça le débat a pris
une perspective nouvelle avec le
scandale des exclusions d'il ya deux ans
bon maintenant il faut pas croire que
la roumanie est traversé par tous par
cette séparation il ya des communautés
qui sont parfaitement intégrés ou les
roumains les les roms les roumains
d'origine aux hommes vivent ensemble il
ya aussi bien sûr des
aussi des communautés où cette
séparation existe à cause de la
stigmatisation ou à cause aussi d'une
d'une culture qui est propre à certains
communauté des roms qui qui ne veulent
pas le contact enfin et qui complique ce
qui complique d'ailleurs d'intervention
sociale il ya pour ainsi d'aider en
touche arbres qui n'accepte pas des noms
roms à l'intérieur des communautés alors
bien sûr que les médiateurs sociaux ont
du mal à faire le travail mais c'est pas
généraliser il faut bien comprendre que
la roumanie je le répète est traversé
par
parcelle de la facture comme ça non
c'est plus compliqué d'ailleurs ce qui
fait que aussi en europe la situation
des roms qui circule est différente il
ya des ya des régions où ça se passe
très bien et chante de nouveau
parfaitement intégrés surtout quand
disons bien sûr du travail et il ya des
situations ils sont marginalisés à la
périphérie
et c'est donc ça des produits en quelque
sorte les situations existantes aux
siens quand même il n'en vendent bien en
quelques chopes en quittant la roumanie
alors il ya eu vous le disiez il ya deux
ans une polémique parce que des roms ont
été expulsés de france c'était lorsque
le président nicolas sarkozy était au
pouvoir cet été de nouveau il ya eu une
polémique alors que maintenant il s'agit
de françois hollande est ce que ça a
changé en tout cas ce que c'est vécu
comme tel est ce que c'est la même
situation aujourd'hui le paradoxe fait
que des explosions étaient organisés
bien avant que début de scandale en 2010
les chiffres d'ailleurs sont
parfaitement comparable c'est que la
seule nouveauté il ya deux ans et qu'on
a commencé par des rentrées ensuite ce
qui est aussi paradoxal c'est que
la plupart des départs des rendre se
sont faits avant 2007 avoue la lentille
de leurs manies en europe or ce qui est
dit dans le débat public c'est cruel à
l'entrée de la roma de l'armagnac lait
sur le feu c'est pas vrai parce que la
plupart je le répète de départ c'était
bien avant maintenant bien sûr qu'avec
des mesures qui n'ont pas toujours bien
taillée j'allais dire l'idée de donner
des de l'argent pour que les roms
quittent le territoire bon sens courage
et les arrivées parce que les gens
apprennent en roumanie le gouvernement
français disponibles dans le pays a une
petite somme bon ils font le parcours
donc il faut uniquement pour repartir
avec les 3 100 euros bien sûr enfin jeu
donc c'est les vraies solutions je crois
que chante à définir au niveau des états
membres en roumanie comme ailleurs où
les robes se trouve maintenant mais
aussi au niveau européen pour chez qui
concerne deux domaines essentiels c'est
à dire l'éducation et la santé tant que
nous n'avons pas un vrai système de dons
très scolaire partout les roms se trouve
maintenant parce qu'ils ne sont plus en
roumanie bulgarie slovaquie qui sont les
trois grands pays où on retrouve cet
énorme minorité européenne
mais les rampes sont partout alors il
faut s'attendre à voir ces nécessité de
les faire entrer à l'école ensuite il
faut bien sûr voir comment gérer la
question sociale parce qu'il ya c'est
vrai on a en roumanie comme dans les
autres pays où il s'installe en vrai
problème social vue là je dis la
fragilité de de l'installation alors
notre reporter en roumanie a rencontré
une étudiante et s'appelle margareta
elle a uni est là une question à vous
poser dans les côtes
de quoi finir je vous pose la question
que doivent faire les roms pour être
accepté par les autres européens et que
doivent-ils faire pour ne pas être
expulsé
un élément de réponse peut-être oui un
élément c'est peut-être surprenant mais
c'est je crois hocine
un problème de représentation politique
vous voyez dans le scandale qui a eu
lieu en france ya deux ans tout le monde
a parlé les roumains les français les
autres europe 1 mais son projet de la
commission sur les institutions il n'y a
pas eu beaucoup de voir homme à qui
s'exprime et cela pourquoi parce que à
la différence des autres minorités
nationales qui chante très bien
représenté en roumanie les roms se sont
pas vraiment bien le présenter il n'y a
pas une vraie mobilisation via des
députés européens roms en fusion un seul
député européen mais qui ne vient pas de
remaniement né de l'envié c'est madame
ya locale qui est membre de notre groupe
et armani aussi pour une population
devant deux millions et avec peut-être
entre 1,5 et 2 millions de roms on a un
seul député aussi qui vient de cette
minorité donc je crois fermement que la
solution ça va être portée si une vraie
mobilisation politique fait si un angle
importante activistes
donc mr voire de resino je sais c'est
très important mais en laissant ce sera
ma dernière question est ce que vous
pensez que la responsabilité revient au
pays dans lesquels vivent vit cette
minorité aujourd'hui donc entre autres
la roumanie ou est ce que c'est une
responsabilité par exemple de la france
et plus globalement que l'ensemble de
l'europe non je crois comme il s'agit de
citoyens européens des responsabilités
prévient à chacun des pays riches où il
choisit de vivre de bien subit encore
des restrictions vous l'avez mentionné
mais il faut s'attendre qu'après 2014
chacun des états membres où ils
choisissent de s'installer fasse quelque
chose pour l'éducation et pour la santé
merci christian preda d'avoir accepté
notre invitation c'est la fin d'europe
hebdo on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine au parlement européen avec
kathia gilder d'ici là bonne suite des
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
oh